[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau l'anatomie comparée pour
les nuls cette fois ci avec des dragons
et autres reliques conservés dans les
églises car le saviez-vous ou non mais
les églises sont souvent le lieu de
dépôt d'ossements alors bien souvent ce
sont des ossements humains des ossements
de sein qui sont conservés comme des
reliques
mais des fois plus ou moins consciemment
et ben ils ont conservé des ossements
d'animaux et ça ce sont des cas très
intéressant à discuter d'un point de vue
anatomique on paraît donc aujourd'hui on
va parler de quelques-uns de ces cas là
les plus intéressants que j'ai pu glaner
ci et là sur internet mais évidemment si
vous en connaissez d'autres n'hésitez
pas à les présenter dans les
commentaires alors on commence par le
fameux cas des reliques de jeanne d'arc
qui sont conservés un chinon et qui sont
la propriété de l'archevêché ces
reliques
elles contiennent de nombreux ossements
qui ont été analysés ils se sont rendu
compte en fait que certains ossements
étaient effectivement des ossements
humains mais qui n'étaient pas des
ossements humains brûlé mais simplement
momifiée et c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient
noirs en fait il était en entouré de
produits de momification qui avait
pourri et qui était devenu noir mais ils
se sont rendu compte quand même que dans
le lot il y avait un os et le voici
cette hausse un fémur qui appartient à
un chat donc ce fémur c'était un os
attribué à jeanne d'arc et qui en fait
ils se sont rendus compte que c'était en
fait un fémur de chat alors comment ils
s'en sont rendu compte et bien c'est là
que ça devient intéressant
déjà la taille alors sur la gauche je
vous ai mis la photo du fémur en
question une des rares photos qu'on peut
trouver sur internet de ce fémur et à
droite je vous ai mis un fémur de chats
comparé à un fémur humain est vraiment
tout à droite je vous ai mis le fémur du
chat à la même échelle que le fémur
humain donc regarder l'échelle indiqué
par la flèche rouge et vous verrez la
différence de taille entre un fémur de
chat et un fémur humain et du coup on se
demande un petit peu comment ils ont
fait pour croire que cet os light est un
os de jeanne d'arc alors pourtant c'est
très facile à identifier comme étant un
fémur
donc je vois pas comment ils ont pu
douter enfin peut-être qu'ils auraient
pris cette hausse là pour autre chose
qu'un fémur
mais c'est quand même très facile à
l'identifier comme un fémur avec cette
grosse tête d'articulation
qui est donc l'articulation avec le
bassin mais donc quand on compare la
taille de ce fémur de chahains fémur
humain on se demande comment ils ont pu
croire que ça ça aurait pu être un fémur
de jeanne d'arc
donc soit ils ont cru que c'était un
autre os mais ça ça semble douteux parce
que quand même il avait des minimum de
connaissances en anatomie
soit ils ont réellement cru que c'était
un fémur humain mais alors ils ont cru
que jeanne d'arc était tout petit
bon le fait est que les reliques en
elles-mêmes n'ont été apportées à chinon
que au 19e siècle donc ce sont des
reliques très récente comparée à la
grande histoire des reliques et on ne
sait même pas d'ailleurs si ce son si
elles ont jamais réellement été
considérés comme de véritables reliques
de manière générale en tout cas c'est un
exemple intéressant de comment d un
fémur de chat a pu finir dans un
reliquaire dédié à probablement la
sainte la plus connue de toute la france
jeanne d'arc et il n'y a pas vraiment de
doute sur le fait que ce fémur
appartient à un chat déjà comme je
voulais dit à la taille mais il ya aussi
et surtout la morphologie de la tête du
fémur et notamment le col du fémur qui
est très très long chez l'humain c'est
pour ça qu'ils se cassent si facilement
d'ailleurs donc le col du fémur et très
longs chez l'humain et vous voyez sur ce
fémur il est plutôt court plutôt
robustes comme celui qu'on retrouve chez
le chat et si vous voulez en savoir plus
à propos de ce fémur et des autres
reliques de jeanne d'arc je vous invite
à lire cet article je vous ai mis le
lien dans la description qui explique
toute l'histoire des reliques contenu
dans le bocal de chinon et qui ont été
analysées très en profondeur
ils ont même fait des datations au
carbone 14 qui ont démontré que ces
reliques daté du temps de l'egypte
antique
donc en fait c'était bel et bien des
ossements qui ont été pillées sur des
momies égyptiennes pour être ensuite
apporté comme relique de jeanne d'arc
on passe maintenant en côte de dragon
les côtes de dragon c'est un grand
classique dans les églises on va voir à
travers cette vidéo qu'il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup et il y en a partout
il ya des bouquins qui ont été écrits
sur les côtes de dragon sur les côtes
qui sont vénérés comme étant des côtes
de dragon il ya des livres entiers qui
ont été écrits là dessus parce qu'il y
en a tellement
donc là on va parler d'eux
de quelques exemples vraiment
sélectionné à gauche vous avez l'église
de sainte-marie de kern grob parce que
je ne sais pas prononcé ce mot ce qui
est slovène et à droite vous avez la
côte du babau donc le baba au s'éteindra
go provençal et cette côte là elle est
conservée à l'église de prats de mollo
alors il existe beaucoup de côtes de
baba eaux dans le sud de la france mais
celle là elle est intéressante parce
qu'elle est encore accrochée à l'église
comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
photo
alors ces côtes de dragon à quoi
peuvent-elles bien avoir appartenu
peuvent-elles avoir appartenu à des
dragons eh bien nous allons faire ce
qu'on appelle de l'anatomie comparée et
comparer ses côtes à des côtes d'animaux
connu alors ici j'ai sélectionné
rhinocéros cheval vaches et port afin de
réaliser des comparaisons avec des
animaux de grande relativement grande
taille parce que ce sont des côtes qui
sont quand même de grande taille comme
vous avez pu le voir alors une cote
c'est quand même un os qui est assez
ingrat niveau anatomy comparer parce
qu'il ya pas grand chose à comparer donc
globalement vous avez la forme générale
de l'os qui est plutôt arqués et vous
avez la tête d'articulation qui peut
avoir
soit un soin d'eux tubercules donc vous
pouvez voir que s'ils ont cette côte qui
vient de sainte-marie-de-kent grob
il n'y a qu'un seul tubercules à la fin
de la cote alors que certaines côtes de
rhinocéros de cheval de vaches et de
porcs ont deux tubercules et certaines
côtes n'ont qu'un seul et en fait il
faut regarder la façon dont ses côtes
sont arrangés de gauche à droite donc
vous voyez pour le rhinocéros par
exemple de gauche à droite vous avez une
cote courte une cote légèrement plus
longue puis 3 cote relativement longue
la dernière étant légèrement plus courte
que les deux précédentes
eh bien ces côtes elles sont organisées
de façon proximo distale de gauche à
droite ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que la cote de gauche la plus petite et
la plus robuste
c'est la côte qui est la plus proche de
la tête et à droite la cote la plus fine
et qui est parmi les plus longues
c'est la côte qui est la plus éloignée
de la tête donc pour chaque animal ou
voyez que ça organisé de cette façon
donc de façon proximo distale les côtes
les plus proches de la tête sont à
gauche les côtes les plus éloignés de la
tête sont à droite et vous pouvez voir
que les côtes qui ont deux
les reculs sont celles qui sont le plus
à gauche donc déjà on peut dire que la
côte de sainte marie de kernault grub2
par le fait qu'elle n'a qu'un seul
tubercules appartient probablement ou
coutlée +10 talent donc les côtes qui
sont les plus éloignés de la tête et ça
c'est intéressant puisque cette côte à
l'est aussi très très arc et comme vous
pouvez le voir elle forme quasiment un
arc de cercle parfait et bien ça ça se
retrouve aussi sur les côtes les plus 10
talent chez le rhinocéros et le cheval
par exemple donc les côtes les plus
distincts celle rhinocéros et le cheval
ce sont celles qui ont la forme la plus
marquée les autres elles ont elles
forment pas un joli arc de cercle comme
c'est le cas chez le rhinocéros et le
cheval d'ailleurs vous noterez que chez
la vache et le port on ne constate pas
cette forme
cette jolie forme en arc de cercle comme
ça elle a raison elle est très simple
c'est parce que le rhinocéros et le
cheval il digère avec leurs intestins
donc la chambre de fermentation qui leur
permet de digérer leur nourriture ce
sont des herbivores et leur chambre de
fermentation se situe dans leurs
intestins donc à l'arrière de leur corps
donc pour accommoder la place à
l'arrière de leur corps il faut que leur
cote soit très très vaste et donc bien
arc et forment un bel arc de cercle
au contraire la vache elle va digérer
avec ses quatre estomacs qui sont très
très efficace et du coup ces quatre
estomacs prennent beaucoup moins de
place que les normes intestins qui est
nécessaire les normes chambre de
fermentation qui est nécessaire pour
ceux qui n'ont pas qui ne sont pas des
ruminants donc cheval et rhinocéros ne
sont pas des ruminants ils ont besoin
d'un énorme tube digestif et donc leur
cote doivent aménager de l'espace pour
ça la vache n'a pas besoin de cet énorme
tube digestif ses côtes n'ont pas besoin
d'aménager autant d' espaces et le port
n'est même pas un herbivore strict c'est
un omnivore
donc c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas non
plus besoin d'autant de l'espace donc
c'est pour ça qu'on voit c'est énorme
cette courbure chez le rhinocéros et le
cheval
alors est ce qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une
cote de rhinocéros ou de cheval s'est
pas complètement impossible mais vous
constatez qu'il ya un problème
d'épaisseur parce que plus on va en
direction distale donc plus on regarde
les côtes qui sont vers la droite et
plus on constate qu'elles deviennent de
plus en plus fines donc les côtes qui
sont à gauche de l'image sont épaisses
et les côtes vers la droite sont plus
fines ça veut dire que les côtes distale
sont généralement plus fine
or cette côte de sainte marie de kent
grob
elle est plutôt épaisse elle est plutôt
épaisse comparé aux autres côtes que je
vous montre sur l'image de droite
donc c'est une côte qui est à la fois
distale et épaisses et ça c'est très
très rare de le rencontrer
sauf chez un groupe de mammifères très
connu et de grande taille qu'on appelle
les cétacés donc vous voyez ici un
squelette de baleine et vous pouvez
constater sur ce squelette de baleine
que les côtes
même les plus éloignés de la tête sont
aussi d'une très très grande épaisseur
et ça c'est pour une raison toute simple
c'est parce que le squelette des
baleines en général le squelette même
des cétacés de tous les cétacés en
général il sert de stockage de graisses
ce que les baleines ont besoin d'un
double stockage de graisses elles ont
besoin de graisse dans leur peau afin de
se maintenir au chaud afin de servir de
couches isolantes
mais cette couche de graisse elles ne
peuvent pas y toucher parce que
justement elle sert d'isolation donc ils
ne peuvent pas l'utiliser en cas de
problème parce que sinon elles vont
mourir de froid
donc elles ont une autre réserve de
graisses et sept autres réserves de
graisse est se situe dans leur zone et
notamment dans leur cote dont vous
pouvez voir qu'elles sont extrêmement
poreuse alors les côtes des autres
mammifères sont aussi poreuse comme la
côte humaine que je vous montre en
section juste à côté
mais la porosité vous voyez n'est pas la
même la côte humaine c'est une porosité
qui est plutôt lâche qui est plutôt
plutôt aléatoire alors que la porosité
des baleines elle est très
compartimentée vous voyez tous ces
petits compartiments voyez toutes ces
petites cellules certes au stockage de
la graisse
donc c'est une porosité qui est vraiment
très très différente de celle qu'on
rencontre chez les autres mammifères
donc les écoutes de baleines certes au
stockage de graisses comme le reste des
eaux et c'est pour ça que les côtes de
cétacés sont généralement plus épaisse
que les cotes des autres mammifères
c'est parce qu'elles ont cette fonction
de stockage que celle des autres
mammifères n'ont pas donc ses côtes de
dragon il s'agit généralement de coude
de cétacés et ça peut être soit des
cétacés qui on était
trouvé sur la plage donc qui se sont
échoués ou alors qu'ils ont été récoltés
par des baleiniers ou parfois ça peut
être des baleines fossiles par exemple
celle de sainte marie de kent robe je ne
serais pas surpris étant donné la
couleur de cette côte qu'il s'agit en
fait d'une cote de cétacés fossiles par
contre celle du babau sur la droite il
pourrait s'agir d'un cétacés modernes
qui a été ramené à l'église de prades de
mollo alors prats de mollo c'est situées
profondément dans les terres donc il ya
aussi la possibilité qu'il s'agisse
d'une cote de baleines fossiles
d'ailleurs l'histoire locale n'est pas
vraiment clair sur l'origine de la côte
s'agit-il d'une cote ramené depuis saint
cyprien où s'agit-il d'une cote locale
qui a été trouvé en creusant les deux
histoires existent mais il ya certains
cas où on est à peu près sûr de la
provenance des côtes notamment dans
l'est dans les villes côtières justement
donc par exemple à venise à l'église
santa maria et centre donato vous avez
ses côtes de cétacés ici situé à
l'arrière de cette photo à gauche qui
sont affichés dans l'église et là on est
à peu près sûr qu'il s'agit d'un cétacés
modernes puisque on est au bord de la
mer et à l'office du tourisme de
rivesaltes il y avait aussi il ya aussi
une côte dite du babau qui est conservé
et qui était autrefois conserver à
l'église et cette côte de baba au c est
à peu près sûr qu'il s'agit d'une côte
qui a été glané sur une baleine moderne
et les restes de cétacés qui sont
entreposés dans les églises ne sont pas
toujours des mauvaises issus de
mauvaises interprétations d'ossements de
baleines des fois il ya des baleines qui
sont conservés volontairement comme par
exemple la grande baleine qui se
trouvent dans la cathédrale sainte bas
vont à gand en belgique
donc cette baleine elle s'est échoué
près de gand en 2015 et et le squelette
a été ramenée et exposées à l'église de
caen parce que elle rappelle la baleine
du fameux passage de la bible avec jonas
qui se fait engloutir par la baleine
alors elle est loin de faire la taille
d'une baleine enfin qu'il faudrait pour
pouvoir engloutir un être humain mais
quand même c'est ça rappelle du coup ce
passage de la bible et donc tous les
ossements de baleines qui sont dans les
églises ne sont pas forcément des
mauvaises interprétations et d'ailleurs
ne sont pas forcément tous interprétés
comme appartenant à des dragons et la
plupart des côtes de baleines qui sont
encore conservées aujourd'hui dans les
airs
d'ailleurs ne sont plus identifié comme
appartenant à autre chose qu'à des
baleines donc elles ne sont plus vénérés
comme appartenant à des dragons ou à des
géants ou un que sais-je
autre curiosité qu'on peut rencontrer
dans les églises en matière de dragons
et bien ce sont les dragons qui sont en
fait des crocodiles empaillés
donc ce sont des crocodiles qui ont été
ramenés parfois il ya très longtemps à
l'époque médiévale parfois plus
récemment au 19e siècle et que la
culture locale a réinterprété en fait
comme appartenant à un dragon locale
donc c'est par exemple le cas du dragon
de la cathédrale saint bertrand de
comminges où par exemple du dragon de la
collégiale de saint maurice doiron donc
ces deux crocodiles qui sont aujourd'hui
totalement identifié comme étant des
crocodiles je veux dire même les gens
qui travaillent dans l'église sont
d'accord pour dire que ce sont des
crocodiles et que ce sont pas des
dragons mais à l'époque quand ils ont
été ramenés bien le folklore local les a
interprétés comme étant des
représentations du dragon locale puisque
la plupart des lieux catholiques ont
généralement un dragon locale vous
pouvez mettre le nom du vôtre dans les
commentaire voilà ce qu'ils vivent à
metz on leur graouilly ceux qui vivent
près de rivesaltes ont le baba au ceux
qui vivent dans l'est on lave ou ivres
ceux qui vivent ce qu'ils vivent en
camargue on la tarasque donc voilà vous
avez normalement si vous faites vos
petites recherches vous allez rapidement
découvrir que votre ville ou que votre
village à son dragon locales ou du moins
où la région à un dragon locale donc
c'est des fois ces crocodiles qui ont
été ramenés à leur soit par des
voyageurs soit par des pèlerins soit par
des collectionneurs ou qu'elle sèche ce
sont des dons il ya beaucoup de ex voto
aussi qui ont été faits vous en avez un
par exemple à collioure dans le sud de
la france vous avez un ex voto qui en
fait un don qui a été fait à l'église
d'un crocodile empaillé n'a jamais été
question que ce soit un dragon ça a
toujours été un crocodile mais c'est
juste un don qui a été fait à l'église
c'est pour qu'un voeu se réalise en fait
c'est ça un ex voto mais là les deux que
je vous présente et bien ils ont été
interprétés comme des dragons à l'époque
où ils ont été ramenés et évidemment
comme je voulais dit il n'y a pas de
doute sur le fait qu'il s'agit bien de
crocodiles d'ailleurs on peut même en
profiter pour vérifier s'il s'agit de
crocodiles
d'alligator en regardant la forme de
leur museau donc le museau des
alligators et paraboliques donc
complètement arrondie alors que le
museau de crocodile et légèrement passé
à l'avant ce qui lui fait cette forme de
bulbe à l'avant du museau donc le museau
est partie pour être triangulaire et
puis vous avez ce pincement qui lui
donne cette forme de bulbe finale où se
trouve justement les naseaux et bien là
on peut tout à fait voir ce pincement
sur les dragons des cathédrales de la
cathédrale de saint bertrand de
comminges et sur le dragon de douaron
donc il s'agit bel et bien de crocodile
et non pas de d'alligator ou de cayman
ou de jeunes sikhs ont un peu plus de
challenge maintenant avec le dragon de
vaval donc le smicval skis qui est
exposé à la cathédrale de vannes près de
cracovie en pologne
alors ce smicval skis il est constitué
de trois ossements deux petits en haut
et en bas et un très très grand au
milieu mais en fait il ya un très très
grand et deux gros en haut et en bas
comme vous allez le voir c'est un peu
dur de se rendre compte de l'échelle
mais vous pouvez voir par rennes par
rapport à la taille du vitrail à côté
la taille des ossements est quand même
assez gigantesque alors voici une autre
angle de vue sur ces ossements là on va
commencer par le lancement du bas qui
est le plus simple à identifier
puisqu'il s'agit d'un crâne et ce crâne
on peut y voir deux choses d'une part à
l'avant qu'il a une ouverture nasale
extrêmement vaste indiqué par cette
flèche rouge et sur le dessus que la
forme de l'ariège crâne est en forme de
u une forme allégée eu et ça c'est très
typique des crânes de rhinocéros donc
vous avez ici à gauche à rhinau seros
blanc à droite un rhinocéros de java
pour bien couvrir le spectre de
diversité anatomiques des rhinocéros un
des plus grand au plus petit et bien
c'est ces rhinocéros vous pouvez voir
qu'ils ont tous les deux cette forme en
u sur le sommet du crâne et ils ont tous
les deux une ouverture nasale
extrêmement grande
c'est très typique des rhinocéros donc
là on est sur du mammifère mais même
sans les dents on arrive quand même à
aller sur une identification assez
précise néanmoins en l'absence de dents
donc ce qui vous a indiqué ici par ce
cercle
on va avoir du mal à décider qu'est ce
qu'on est en train de regarder puisque
les rhinocéros moderne se différencie
essentiellement par leur morphologie
dentaire vous pouvez voir que le
rhinocéros blanc n'a pas d'assise y va
que le rhinocéros de java il a un bon
complexe d'incisives celle du haut en
forme de forme plate et celle du bas en
forme de défense
donc là en l'absence de dents on peut
pas vraiment on est un peu coincé ou du
moins on pourrait être coincé si on
n'était pas plus perspicaces que ça
puisque l'on va faire preuve de
perspicacité et on va regarder donc ces
fameux deux angles de vue qu'on a du
dragon de babel de plus près donc un
gauche je vous ai mis un agrandissement
de la photo qui est là depuis tout à
l'heure et à droite c'est un
agrandissement de la première photo que
je vous ai mis donc sur ces deux
agrandissements on peut voir que le
septembre nasale c'est à dire le morceau
d'os qui sépare les deux narines et très
épais alors déjà généralement chez les
mammifères il n'existe pas de symptômes
nasale il n'y a pas de séparation entre
les deux narines vous regardez le crâne
de n'importe quel mammifères vous verrez
que les deux narines sont fusionnés donc
déjà voir la présence d'un septum nasal
qui sépare les deux narines
c'est déjà un énorme à 10 ans soit parce
qu'il ya quasiment aucun mammifère qui
possède çà et là en plus vous pouvez
voir que le setom nasale est extrêmement
épais pourquoi parce qu'il portait une
corne donc une corne qui est qui était
probablement gigantesque et ça c'est
tout à fait typique d'un rhinocéros bien
connu et il n'est pas moderne il est
faux cils il s'agit du rhinocéros
laineux
vous pouvez voir sur ces deux photos de
crâne de rhinocéros laineux qui
reproduisent à peu près les deux mêmes
vues que celle que je vous ai mis en bas
que le rhinocéros laineux il a non
seulement 1 septembre qui sépare les
deux narines vous pouvez voir cette
bande osseuse qui part du dessus du
crâne et se prolonge jusque le dessous
du crâne et qui sépare complètement les
deux narines et vous pouvez voir que
cette bande osseuse est épaisse et très
rieuse parce qu'elles portaient les
normes cornes dont on sait que les
rhinocéros laineux étaient équipés alors
est il possible que le dragon de vaval
soit en fait au moins en partie à
rhinocéros laineux et bien c'est tout à
fait possible parce que l'histoire de
co2 l'origine de ces ossements est tout
à fait connu la légende raconte que ses
os ont été trouvés dans la grotte du
dragon qui se trouve à cracovie et qui
est toujours visitable aujourd'hui vous
voyez l'entrée de cette grotte avec une
reproduction du dragon qui crache des
flammes en plus
autant dire qu'ils y ont mis les moyens
donc c'est au ils viennent d'une grotte
qui l environnement de dépôt typique des
ossements d'animaux du pléistocène comme
le sont le comme le sont les rhinocéros
laineux
donc il est tout à fait possible en
réalité que ce dragon de babel soit un
rhinocéros laineux et d'ailleurs ce
serait pas le premier rhinocéros laineux
qu'on aurait pris pour un dragon puisque
ici vous avez le ligne vous remet de
klagenfurt en autriche
vous avez une statue de ce ligne boom de
klagenfurt et on sait que cette statue a
été réalisé d'après le modèle d'un crâne
de rhinocéros laineux qui avait était
interprété dans les années 1500 comme
appartenant à ce dragon donc est ce
crâne il est toujours visible
aujourd'hui aux naturistes riches
landès museum mon allemand est terrible
mais voilà le crâne qui a servi
d'inspiration au dragon aux lignes de
vue l'homme de klagenfurt était un crâne
de rhinocéros laineux comme celui du
dragon de valbelle donc ce serait pas la
première fois qu'on interprète les
rhinocéros laineux comme étant des
dragons donc maintenant qu'en est il des
deux autres ossements alors on va
continuer avec l'osm ans qui est le plus
en hausse celui du dessus alors on a on
peut voir sur cet os manque il possède
de gros cons deal articulaires à une
extrémité est un conte deal articulaires
à l'autre extrémité ce qui en fait un
fémur
donc vous pouvez voir qu'il est tout à
fait similaire à un fémur humain encore
que pas tout à fait il y a des
différences notables et la première
différence bas c'est déjà la taille vous
pouvez voir comme je le rappelle le
fémur il est gigantesque vous pouvez
voir qu'il est quasiment de là il est
plus long même que le crâne d'un
rhinocéros laineux adultes et encore une
fois je vous renvoie à la taille du
vitrail à côté donc c'est un fémur assez
gigantesque ainsi titanesque qu'on a là
et il a une différence notable avec le
fémur humain c'est que il ne possède pas
de trop quand air donc le tronquant
terre c'est un genre de petites bosses
enfin plus ou moins petit boss qui se
trouve sur le côté du fémur il peut y en
avoir plusieurs de ces trochanter et ce
fémur là celui du dragon doivent elles
ne possèdent pas de trop quand air il
est complètement lisse des deux côtés et
donc ça ça exclu directement le
rhinocéros laineux donc ce fémur ne peut
pas avoir appartenu à un rhinocéros
laineux car les fémurs de rhinos
ross laineux comme ceux d'ailleurs de
tous les rhinocéros possède deux
gigantesques trochanter bien visible sur
le côté de l'os donc déjà on peut
exclure que cette hausse appartient à un
rhinocéros laineux aussi contrairement
au crâne
alors à quoi appartient-il ce fémur s'il
ne s'agit pas de celui d'un rhinocéros
laineux alors que nous indique cette
absence de trochanter et bien cette
absence de trochanter elle nous indique
qu'on est face au fémur d'un animal qui
était grave y porter gravi porter ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que cet animal avait les
jambes disposés en colonne en dessous du
corps et ses jambes elle était
complètement droite elle n'était pas
légèrement infléchi comme peuvent l'être
par exemple si vous regardez votre chat
quand ils chassent il est capable de
fléchir ses jambes et bien cet animal
l'animal auquel appartenait ce fémur et
bien il était incapable de fléchir ses
jambes comme le chat le fait et ça ça a
une implication fonctionnelles majeures
ça veut dire que cet animal était
incapable de galoper il ne pouvait que
marcher vite hélas déjà normalement ça
doit commencer à vous mettre la puce à
l'oreille
alors sachant qu' on n'a pas
complètement exclu qu'il pouvait s'agir
du fémur d'un animal fossiles il va
falloir regarder à travers le registre
fossile
quels sont les animaux qui avaient des
membres gravi porter et qui donc n'avait
pas ce genre de troc en terre alors
quand on regarde le registre fossile on
a évidemment les sauropodes parmi les
plus grands animaux qui ont vécu sur
terre c'est sauropodes comme vous pouvez
le voir non pas de trochanter leur fémur
est complètement lisse et ça ça a dit
que comme le seul animal qui est devant
nous leurs membres étaient bien droit
sous leur corps et ne pouvaient pas
galoper on a aussi le para serra terium
comme bon candidat
plus connu sous le nom de hendrix terium
ballouchy therion donc le plus grand
mammifère terrestre qui ait jamais
existé qui est en fait un rhinocéros
gigantesque avec un long cou et puis on
a les mammouths les mammouths qui sont
comme les éléphants des animaux gravi
porter qui n'était pas capable de courir
et vous pouvez voir ici que leur fémur
ne possède pas non plus de trop quand
air alors lequel de ces trois candidats
et le plus
et le plus vraisemblable selon moi c'est
le mammouth pour la simple et bonne
raison que on a déjà identifié un
rhinocéros laineux et que d'après
l'histoire de l'origine qu'on connaît de
ses ossements ils viennent tous de la
même grotte
donc on va partir du principe qu'ils ont
été très probablement trouver tous en
même temps et au même endroit et ce qui
veut dire qu'on est face à une faune
pléistocène
et en plus le mammouth correspond très
bien anatomiquement à ce fémur
notamment vous pouvez identifier les
deux candidats l'arrière et vous pouvez
surtout identifié vous voyez cette
petite fosse qui se trouve sur le sommet
de l'osce alors j'ai essayé de
l'orienter à peu près de trouver une
photo de fémur de mammouth qui soit
orientée à peu près de la même façon
c'est pas une correspondance parfaite au
niveau de l'orientation mais vous pouvez
voir qu'il y à cette fausse qui se
trouve au sommet de l'osce et qu'on
retrouve aussi sur le fémur du dragon de
babel les dimensions sont parfaitement
cohérente avec celle du dragon travel
donc on est très très probablement en
face d'un fémur de mammouth
ici donc passons maintenant au dernier
ross qui est celui du milieu le plus
grand et donc rien que par sa taille
vous pouvez voir que cette hausse sur
passe de très loin la taille du crâne du
rhinocéros laineux et du fémur de
mammouth
donc ça ça va nous exclure à peu près
toutes les espèces terrestres qui ont pu
exister
rien que par sa taille gigantesque cette
hausse est beaucoup plus grand que
n'importe quel autre os appartenant à un
animal terrestre qu'il va falloir
regarder du côté des animaux marins et
comme on est probablement sur des os qui
viennent tous d'un dépôt au pléistocène
on va regarder du côté des mammifères
marins à savoir les baleines donc rien
que par la taille on peut déjà éliminé
un énorme paquet de candidats et ne
conserver que les plus grandes espèces
de baleines à savoir les baleines à
fanons où les cachalots et on va tuer le
suspense tout de suite
il s'agit en fait d'une mâchoire de
cétacés comparé à celui d'une baleine
bleue on arrive à retrouver certains
éléments donc déjà il ya la courbure
général de l'oce qui correspond très
bien à la courbure de la mâchoire d'une
baleine
on voit ce petit ce petit processus
orientés vers le haut sur le squelette
de la baleine indiqué par la flèche
rouge et qui a indiqué à
gauche sur le dragon de javel ce petit
processus s'appelle le processus
choroïde c'est là que vient sa tâche et
le muscle temporal chez les mammifères
et vous avez ce groupe processus entouré
en rouge qui correspond aux candidats
articulaires c'est-à-dire à
l'articulation de la mâchoire avec le
crâne de la baleine
vous pouvez aussi noter que l'autre
extrémité de cette mandibules est
arrondi et on retrouve cette même forme
arrondie chez les baleines à fanons tout
simplement parce que chez les baleines à
fanons contrairement aux êtres humains
par exemple et bien les deux mandibules
ne sont pas fusionner les deux
mandibules sont capables de bouger
indépendamment l'une de l'autre et ça ça
les aide à séparer leurs mâchoires quand
il s'agit d'un gouffre et d'énormes
quantités de dos contenant du plancton
ou ou du poisson donc là ce qu'on voit
avec le dragon de la vesle en fait c'est
une mâchoire qui est vu par le dessous
donc j'ai essayé de repositionner avec
cet oeil la façon dont on voit la
mâchoire du dragon de la vesle sur cette
photo avec l'intérieur qui est du côté
interne de la courbure et l'extérieur de
la mâchoire qui est du côté externe de
la courbure alors on a une anatomie qui
correspond relativement bien à celui
d'une baleine à fanons pourrait-il
s'agir d'un cachalot et bien la réponse
est non bon d'une part parce que les
cachalots ont des dents mais même mais
néanmoins comme on ne voit cette
mâchoire que du dessous on pourrait se
dire que les dents sont cachées elles
sont de l'autre côté de la mâchoire mais
ce qui va être déterminant ici ça va
être d'une part l'épaisseur de la
mandibule donc vous voyez que la
mandibule du dragon de javel est épaisse
sur toute sa longueur alors que celle
d'un cachalot est très épaisse à
l'arrière est très fine à l'avant et
puis ce qui va être déterminant aussi
c'est l'absence d'une fosse à l'arrière
de la mâchoire donc chez les cachalots à
l'arrière de la mâchoire
vous avez une espèce de cavités qui est
normalement fait pour accueillir un
récepteur qui est un récepteur à
ultrasons alors ces faits de tissus
graisseux donc le cachalot étant équipé
d'un sonar comme les dauphins
il va émettre des ultrasons et c'est
ultra sons vous rebondir sur ses proies
ou sur l'environnement autour de lui
vous revenir à lui et 7 et qu il va le
capter avec sa mâchoire mâchoire qui est
relié à son oreille interne qui va
interpréter ces sons et le cachalot
possède une fausse
cavités dans chacune de ses mâchoires
pour accueillir ce récepteur cette
espèce d'organes gré ce qui va servir de
récepteurs les baleines à fanons sont
dépourvus de ce récepteur parce que les
baleines à fanons ne pratiquent pas les
colocations et vous pouvez voir sur la
photo du dragon de babel qu' il n'y a
pas de cavités pour accueillir le
récepteur donc cette mandibules est à
coup sûr la mandibule d'une baleine à
fanons donc le dragon doivent elles
n'existent pas en tout cas ces ossements
ne sont pas la preuve de l'existence du
dragon de babel puisque l'os duo est un
fémur probablement de mammouth l'os du
milieu est une mâchoire de baleines à
fanons et l'os du bas est en fait à
crâne de rhinocéros laineux donc il ne
s'agit même pas d'un seul animal en fait
il s'agit de trois animaux complètement
différent et dans les églises on ne
trouve pas que des reliques mais des
fois on trouve aussi juste des
curiosités qui ont été déposés là
quelque part au 19e ou 20e siècle parce
qu'on savait pas trop où les maîtres
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de musée local
ou que sais-je
et c'est le cas de lies qui osent hors
de l'église saint-andré de stalkers et
qui se trouve en angleterre pas si loin
du site de lyme regis qui avait rendu
mary anning célèbre justement parce
qu'il allie découvrait beaucoup de
reptiles marins mésozoïque donc ça
titille aux orres vous pouvez voir est
très reconnaissable
il a une longue queue on voit le tronc
avec les côtes
on voit ces deux palettes natatoire et
alors on a l'impression qu'il ya un
crâne à l'avant mais alors c'est
peut-être juste une vertèbre qui est
couché en fait et qui on dirait que ça
forme un oeil mais c'est peut-être pas
forcément l'allumé en tout cas la
morphologie est très très semblable à
celle d'annick trésors tels qu'on les
connaît donc et celui là il a juste été
déposé là en guise de curiosité quelque
part à l'époque victorienne et on a un
peu perdu la trace d'ailleurs de son
origine en tout cas c'est sur celui-là
il a jamais été interprétée comme étant
un dragon donc maintenant on va aborder
un cas qui est très intéressant et c'est
le cas du dinosaure de la cathédrale de
viger vanot en italie alors ce cas il
est très intéressant parce que en fait
ça jamais été une mauvaise
interprétation d'un truc qui a été
entreposé volontairement dans une église
ça a été la mauvaise interprétation d'un
truc qui a été entreposé a
volontairement dans une église et cette
mauvaise interprétation n'a pas
été fait par des gens qui n'étaient pas
éduqué en anatomie comparer elle a été
faite par un paléontologue par un
paléontologue italien donc tous a
expliqué dans un article que je vous
mettrai en descriptions et dont vous
voyez une capture d'écran sur la gauche
alors ce dinosaure de la cathédrale de
viger vanot à quoi il ressemble et bien
c'est le grossissement que vous voyez à
droite on vous voyez cette disposition
de choses blanche dans le marbre donc
vous voyez que c'est un fossile qui est
dans le marbre qui a été utilisé pour
construire une partie de la cathédrale
donc ici une partie de l'hôtel
alors comment ce fossile s'est retrouvé
interprété comme appartenant à un crâne
de dinosaures et bien je vous ai comparé
en fait ce fossile à un crâne de
dinosaures vu du dessous et donc vous
pouvez voir à droite que les petites
ornementations blanche et dans clé il
s'agirait des dents du dinosaure vous
pouvez voir les deux trous au milieu du
fossile il s'agirait des narines interne
du dinosaure c'est à dire c'est qu'au
anne
alors qu'est ce que c'est l'écho année
bien c'est quand vous respirez par le
nez vous sentez l'air qui rentre dans
vos narines à l'extérieur donc c'est vos
narines externe et qui ensuite passe au
dessus de votre palais pour rentrer dans
votre gorge directement à l'arrière de
la bouche et bien qu'en l'air rentrer à
l'arrière de la bouche il lors il rentre
par là par les narines interne donc vous
avez vos narines externe qui sont
connectés à des narines interne qui se
trouve à l'arrière de votre bouche et
les dinosaures en tout cas certains
dinosaures ont ça aussi donc ça il
pourrait s'agir des narines interne et
après l'espace vide et arrondies qui se
trouve à l'arrière pourrait constituer
l'arrière crâne la boîte crânienne
là où se trouvait le cerveau de l'animal
alors cette interprétation n'est pas
complètement stupide mais elles
négligent une partie du fossile et je
vais vous montrer maintenant
j'isole notre fossiles j'augmente le
contraste et la luminosité et là
soudainement vous voyez apparaître sur
la droite à l'avant des dents en tout
cas à l'avant de ce qu'on avait
interprété comme étant les dents on voit
apparaître plus de structures plus de ce
fossile donc ce fossile ne s'arrête pas
aux dents donc ça veut dire que c'est
certainement pas un crâne en tout cas il
ne
rien ne se trouve à l'avant des dents
normalement sur un crâne normal alors de
quoi pourrait-il s'agir alors là je vous
ai reproduit avec un schéma très très
très simplifié la silhouette du fossile
dans son entièreté donc voici tout le
fossile vous pouvez voir qu'il est à
gauche il est très épais qu'il devient
plus fin à droite et qu'il redevient
épais et cette anatomie elle correspond
exactement à ce qu'on verrait sur une
section transverses d' une ammonite
alors quand vous vous trouvez des
ammonites sur les marchés aux fossiles
généralement ils vous donnent une
section sagittale de la monnaie
c'est-à-dire une section qui est fait
dans la longueur de la monit parce que
c'est plus joli et que ça se vend mieux
mais si on fait une section dans l'autre
sens perpendiculaire à ça et bien voici
ce qu'on voit on voit une section
transverse de la bonite et cette section
transverse de l'amanite voyez qu'elle
est compartimenté on y voit trois
compartiments
le compartiment un qui est le plus grand
à l'extérieur le compartiment 2 qui est
moyen vers l'intérieur et tout au milieu
vous avez un compartiment qui est en
fait un ensemble de plein de petits
compartiments qu'on appelle l'ombilic
c'est le milieu de la money tu es
ensuite vous repassez on compartiment 2
et ensuite vous repasser au compartiment
un don vous avez une certaine symétrie
en fait de cette section de l'amanite
qui correspond parfaitement à la
symétrie qu'on voit sur le fossile de la
cathédrale de viger vanot hélas que je
vous montre c'est une figure qui vient
d'un article qui a été écrit par inoue
et condos en 2016 ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est qu'ils ont passé des ammonites aux
rayons x dans un city scanner c'est
comme un scanner médical sauf que ça
prendrait ça envoie beaucoup plus de
rayons pour pouvoir passer à travers la
roche et ce à une plus haute résolution
ça en voit tellement de rayons que
saturé un être humain mais évidemment
les fossiles sont déjà morts donc on
s'en fout on passe les fossiles là
dedans et ça permet de voir l'intérieur
des fossiles et là en fait ce qu'ils ont
extrait donc les images c d et e f g sur
cette figure représente les septs homme
qui sépare les cavités des ammonites
donc les ammonites c'est pas comme une
coquille d'escargot c'est pas une grosse
qualité à l'intérieur s'est séparé en
plein de petites chambres et entre
chacune de ces chambres qui était une
chambre de vie de
hymne à la une étape de sa croissance
entre chacune de ces chambres vous avez
dès septembre vous avez des murs
d'ailleurs on devrait dire des septs a
vu qu'au pluriel on doit dire cpta donc
un 70 des septs à les latinistes vont me
taper si je dis pas certain mais bref
c'est cpta ils sont une morphologie très
particulière chez les ammonites ils sont
d'une très très grande complexité il son
père s'il est comme on dit des fois et
ça leur donne une très très grande
complexité alors maintenant je vous
isole lancar eu de cette figure et je
voulais la grandit et je vous le place à
côté du fossile de la cathédrale de
viger n'avons hélas normalement vous
comprenez tout vous voyez que sur cette
section d'ammonites reconstruite par
inoue condos en 2016
on retrouve exactement la même structure
que sur le dinosaure de la cathédrale de
viger n'avons donc on retrouve notamment
les deux narines interne
en tout cas ce qui avait été interprété
comme étant les deux narines interne
on le retrouve très bien sur la manette
il s'agit pas du tout de narines interne
évidemment pas chez les amanites et sur
tout ce qu'on avait interprété comme
étant les dents et bien il s'agit en
fait de cette structure persil est très
complexe très dentelée qui sont typiques
des septs à des ammonites donc notre
dinosaures de viger naveau n'est pas du
tout un dinosaure mais il s'agit bien
d'un fossile du mésozoïque hainaut et en
l'occurrence celui d'une âme audit
bon alors le dinosaure de viger naveau
je vous avoue c'était un cas
relativement compliqué c'est un peu
compliqué à interpréter ça fait appel à
beaucoup de jargon alors on va se
détendre avec le l'envié de dresde alors
les langues et qu'est ce que c'est bien
ce sont des structures un peu artistique
comme vous pouvez voir sur lesquels on
accrochait des glo soap être des glo
soap être sont donc des langues
pétrifié et la croyance populaire
voulait que en trempant ses glossop être
dans votre verre de vin bien ça le salon
les vrais le poison éventuelles qu'elle
contiendrait vous pouvez voir que là
vous avez ces langues qui sont suspendus
et qu'ils sont en bonne position pour
que vous puissiez les tremper dans votre
verre de vin et bien c'est glossop être
il s'agit en fait de dents de requin et
en l'occurrence de dents de requin
fossile donc vous voyez celles qui sont
suspendues tout autour il s'agit de
dents du genre ysu rue
et la dent qui se trouve tout au sommet
vous voyez qu'il ya la vierge marie avec
l'enfant est juste derrière elle il ya
une grosse dent et bien c'est évidemment
une dent dure qu'un mieux au pliocène
megalodon alors se languit l'a jamais
vraiment été gardé dans une église
il appartenait plutôt à une riche
famille mais vous pouvez voir que la
structure religieuse dessus et quand
même assez évidente pour qu'on puisse le
qualifier de deux sortes de reliques
voilà et puis c'était juste pour se
détendre tournons nous maintenant vers
les géants les fameux géant qu'on
retrouve si souvent sur l'internet sous
forme de squelette photoshopée dans des
fouilles archéologiques qui n'ont jamais
eu lieu
eh bien ces géants on en a quand même
quelques fossiles alors on en a déjà
parlé plusieurs fois dans d'autres
vidéos de ces fossiles de géant
je vous remets très des liens je vous
mettrais une petite notification là haut
mais là je vais attirer votre attention
sur deux géants qui ont été conservés
dans des églises le premier c'est le
géant de l'abbaye de krems dont on a un
peu perdu la trace depuis donc tout ce
qu'on a c'est cette photo qui a été
publié en 1945 je crois par le
paléontologue au ténénio abel donc ce
géant de l'abbaye de crème et bien c'est
une dans une danse géante qui a été
interprété comme appartenant un être
humain géant des temps bibliques des
temps anciens et donc il était conservé
dans l'abbaye comme précieuses reliques
est en fait là sa comparaison avec une
molaire de mammouth a assez rapidement
démontré qu'il s'agissait en fait d'une
dent qui appartenait à un proboscidiens
donc cette dent était effectivement
géante mais comparé à l'animal auquel
elle appartenait rell était de taille
tout à fait moyenne on y reconnaît
notamment les racines vous voyez qu'il y
a deux racines à l'arrière et une grosse
racine à l'avant donc de petites racines
à l'arrière une grosse racine à l'avant
comme sur la molaire de mammouth et on y
reconnaît le très grand nombre de
lamelles bien que la dent de crem ce
soit relativement abîmé mais on y
reconnaît le très grand nombre de
lamelles qui permet d'ailleurs
d'identifier ce mammouth comme étant un
mammouth laineux
il ya beaucoup d'espèces de mammouths il
ya pas que le mammouth laineux dans la
vie mais celui qui a un grand nombre de
lamelles disposer très proches les unes
des autres et très serré c'est le
mammouth laineux donc le géant de
l'abbaye de krems était en fait un
mammouth laineux
il appert s'abriter magritte et vous
avez l'os deux géants de la cathédrale
saint-etienne de vienne qui est
maintenant entreposés au musée qui se
trouve non loin de là le musée de vienne
ce géant de la cathédrale saint-etienne
de vienne vous pouvez voir déjà de par
sa taille qu'il est effectivement
gigantesque que cet os donc les
extrémités sont cassés mais vous pouvez
voir que l'os tout entier devait mesurer
un bon mètre de haut
ce qui correspondrait à la taille d'un
fémur de mammouth et vous pouvez voir
que comme sur le fémur de mammouth
on y constate l'absence totale de
trochanter et la présence d'une petite
fosse
d'un côté qui correspond très bien la
petite fosse que je vous ai montré tout
à l'heure sur le mammouth de babel et on
va tout de suite arrêter de faire du
mystère évidemment il s'agit d'un
fragment de fémur de mammouth
vous pouvez le voir ici replacer sur un
fémur de mammouth entier pour voir
comment il s'adapte et on voit notamment
bien comment la fosse duo se positionne
par rapport à la fosse quand elle est
complète sur le fémur de mammouth et on
peut voir que donc les deux condyle donc
les deux grosses boules articulaires qui
forment le genou normalement ont été
coupés mais on peut toujours reconnaître
les vases mans en fait de l'os qui
conduisait à ses comptes il est donc ces
deux géants celui de la cathédrale
saint-etienne et celui de l'abbaye de
crem ce ne sont pas des géants mais
appartiennent tous les deux à des
mammouths probablement les neuf et un
truc intéressant à propos des géants
c'est qu'il ya encore beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui qui pour des raisons
religieuses croient en l'existence des
géants du passé et continue de collecter
des fossiles en s'imaginant qu'ils
appartiennent à des géants alors vous
avez notamment le géant de sardaigne
je vous mets un lien dans la description
pour voir d'où vient cette photo du
géant de sardaigne ça vient d'un site du
faux logique de gens qui prétendent
avoir trouvé des ossements de géant et
il ya notamment cette dent qui fait
partie de la collection et vous avez là
dedans géante du bouddha dans qui n'est
pas gênante parce que le bouddha était
un géant mais dans qui est géante
parce que elle continuerait de grandir
donc ça déjà déjà de l'aca c'est un
concept intéressant la dent du bouddha
qui est géante parce qu'elle continue de
grandir parce que les dents des humains
adultes en partant du principe que
bouddha était un être humain adulte
normalement de grandissent plus les
humains ne font pas partie de ces
espèces de mammifères dont les dents
continue de grandir une fois qu'elles
sont sorties
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
continuerait grandir une fois que
bouddha serez mort c'est une bonne
question mais bref
en tout cas il s'agit du vraiment d'une
relique qui est conservée donc c'est la
seule relique que je vais vous montrer
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas conservé dans
une église
elle est conservée dans un temple
bouddhiste et est vénérée comme étant la
dent du bouddha en tout cas une des
nombreuses dents du bouddha puisque il
existe plus d'une dent de bouddha
évidemment bouddha avait 32 dents comme
tout le monde donc il y existe plus
d'une dent de bouddha alors à quoi
correspondent ces dents et bien pour ça
il va falloir faire un petit peu de
cours d'anatomie dentaire de mammifères
membres mon passage préféré à ceux qui
ont vu les vidéos les cours de
mammalogie savent que l'anatomie
dentaire c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
marrant à faire chez les mammifères ou
ce qu'il ya de plus suicidaire aussi si
vous n'aimez pas ça alors les dents de
mammifères
on peut les diviser en cinq types il ya
cinq types d'anatomie de dents de
mammifères con qu'on utilise pour
l'anatomie comparée alors le premier en
haut à gauche c'est le type bras qui
donne donc le type bras qui donc ce sont
les dents qui ont une couronne basse
typiquement les dents humaines
ce type de lembras qui donc ont l'eau
pose aux dents ips dont tu donc
typiquement les dents de cheval ont des
dents ips d'onde c'est à dire des dents
ou la couronne est très très hot ça veut
pas dire qu'elle grandit toute leur vie
ça veut dire qu'elle va grandir pendant
très longtemps mais au bout d'un moment
elle va s'arrêter de grandir une fois
que la couronne sera suffisamment haute
pour résister à l'érosion due à la
mastication de l'herbe puisque l'herbe
contient des petits cristaux de silice
qu'on appelle des phyto lite et qui sont
un mécanisme de défense contre justement
les herbivores brouteurs donc les
herbivores brouteurs ce fusil les dents
sur ces cristaux de silice et les
herbivores brouteurs du coup évoluent en
parallèle et s'adapte et sel et la
première de ces adaptations c'est
l'évolution de dents ipso dont tu as
couronne très très hot
afin que l'usure affecte moins en fait
leur capacité de mastication donc les
dents il se donne ce sont les dents à
couronne très très hot et ensuite vous
avez trois autres types
dedans qu'on définit non pas en fonction
de la hauteur de la couronne mais en
fonction de la morphologie du dessin
dentaire donc les animaux qui ont des
dents à la morphologie dentaire
bulbeuses comme les humains ou les
cochons par exemple ont des dents dit
bruno dhont et vous avez les animaux
dont les dents forme d'el of des l'offre
c'est-à-dire des crêtes et on appelle ça
des dans l'eau faut donc typiquement les
rhinocéros et les tapirs et vous avez
enfin les animaux qui ont des dents
celeno d'onde c'est à dire des dents
dont le dessin dentaire forme
décroissant comme des croissants de lune
d'où le nom celeno dont tu es on
retrouve sa typiquement chez les
ruminants comme par exemple les vaches
donc bruno dhont c'est plutôt une
anatomie d'omnivore lots faut dompter
ces nano donc ce sont plutôt des
anatomies d'herbivores bracchi dont tu
donc la couronne basse c'est plutôt
quelque chose qu'on va retrouver chez
les omnivores et les carnivores
alors que yb seconde c'est quelque chose
qu'on va typiquement retrouver chez les
herbivores et notamment chez ceux qui
mangent de l'herbe les herbivores qui
vont manger surtout des feuilles et des
fruits vont aussi avoir des dents plutôt
bracchi dante ou deux auteurs
intermédiaires et enfin vous avez dansé
codante qui sont les dents coupeuse de
viande qu'on retrouve typiquement chez
les carnivores en maintenant notre dans
de bouddha voici notre dans de bouddha
ou est ce qu'elle va dans tout ça et
bien cette date bouddha vous pouvez
savoir qu'elle a une racine qui est
plutôt courte en rouge et une couronne
qui est très très hot
anvers et ça ça s'accorde très bien avec
la morphologie des dents ips dont
notamment celle des dents de cheval et
la dent du géant de sardaigne qui vient
de notre site du faux logist on peut
voir qu'elle possède une morphologie en
croissant de lune
indiquez ici par des traits orange et
cette morphologie en croissant de lune
comme nous l'avons dit tout à l'heure et
très typique des ruminants donc vu la
taille de la dent il devait s'agir d'un
grands ruminants comme probablement un
buffle ou agir affidés dont on retrouve
d'ailleurs les fossiles abondamment en
italie ainsi qu'en sardaigne
donc il se pourrait qu'il s'agisse en
fait de la dent fossile d'un grand
girafe idée ou d'un
rang d'un autre type de grands ruminants
qui a vécu en sardaigne
pendant le milieu scène où le pliocène
par exemple voilà j'espère que ce petit
tour des églises avant noël vous aura
mille dans l'esprit des fêtes
je vous souhaite une bonne fin de
journée et à très bientôt sur en tracts
aux sciences
[Musique]